I was a specialist in the United States
Army and served in Fort Bragg North
Carolina I'm a native Michigan resident
and so I already knew about Hillsdale
it's a true quality education coming out
that's what i want i wanna i want to
learn stuff not just get a piece of
paper you know the fact that they don't
accept government money so they can
teach what they truly believe without
interference from the government I think
it's a really important part of
Hillsdale when they don't accept
government money of course that includes
the GI bill that would be a big concern
except for they offer military
scholarships and those in my case are
full ride it includes where I live which
isn't just a normal dorm it's off campus
a house it includes tuition includes a
book stipend to five hundred dollars and
includes meals the professor's really
seem to care like if if you come up and
ask them questions they're they're going
to take a personal interest in making
sure you understand the subject they're
teaching and they also care as far as to
whether whether you're actually there or
not it's so small that they actually
came here the transition from the
military to hear was good I'm on the
football team too so there's a little
bit that physicalness still in there if
you're low behind because like me you've
been out for a long time they they
really take a patient's and work with
you and they understand that you haven't
been doing that like everybody else says
for four years straight everything is
just very well put together with
athletics and it's not so much that it's
focused on athletics and that's what
you're expected to only do because the
focus is still on education
you